Thank You leis and something that was my
monologue I hope you all enjoyed it
thank you very much thank you
we go now to : press secretary Andy
Richter press secretary for mr. O'Brian
I will be taking thank you thank you
[Applause]
thank you please we only have limited
time I'll be taking questions from
select members of the press but first
let me just say wow you have just
witnessed one of the finest performances
in the history of monologues that's for
sure yeah right first question you yeah
yes I just want to ask why did Conan
make that audience member touch his
nipple at the top of the show actually
it's our position that that never
happened it is a well-known fact that
Conan does not even have nipples next
question Brian continues to do his
string dance despite the fact that it's
been proven time and time again that
there are no strings attached to his
hips I can't speak to that I mean other
than to say that this is not about
evidence
I mean Conan O'Brien believes that there
are strings attached to his hips which
means there are in fact strings and
there will always be strings attached to
his hips next question please
you use the phrase I can't speak to that
a lot but isn't it your job as Conan's
press secretary to speak to that
I can't speak to that yes this one I
have a question is it true that mr.
O'Brien uses an applause sign to get
approval from the audience I mean that's
utterly absurd and I'm sure that
everyone here agrees with me doesn't
that isn't that right people
okay okay yeah
all right point proven yes yes any truth
to the reports that mr. O'Brien
withdrew a joke at the last minute due
to lack of bipartisan support
no no truth to that at all both the
Jewish writers and the non Jewish
writers liked the joke it was withdrawn
because it was deeply offensive to our
one Norwegian writer we just like to say
sorry Lars sorry okay
Conan always says we have a great show
tonight but sometimes the show isn't
great you think he doesn't have a great
show Conan come on come on come back
here tell him what a great show all
right all right hey take this okay all
right yeah we have got a great show
tonight
stars of the new movie
from It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
and the Fox series the Mik
Kaitlin Olson is here Olsen people mute
against Gary Clark jr. will perform
so coming up we write back Jimmy take it
away
you